um today I'll be speaking about a large
deviation principle for Block models
this is Joint work with Christian and
shuberta who are of course here as well
as Jennifer Chase and Samantha Petty
right um so our work fits in the area of
large deviations for random graphs
um to motivate this area consider GNP
the Irish Freddy random graph
and let T sub n denote the number of
triangles in this graph
let's fix Delta to be positive and let's
consider the probability that the number
of triangles exceeds the expected number
of triangles by like a one plus Delta
multiplicative Factor of course this is
an unlikely event and one question we
could ask is how unlikely is that so
that would be like a typical large
deviation type question
but in addition we might also be
interested in the structure of the graph
conditioned on this unlikely event of
having let's say twice the expected
number of triangles
in other words what is responsible for
an elevated triangle count
is it just that there are more edges
spread throughout the graph
or maybe some small dense graphs like
cliques are responsible for generating
this large number of triangles
um that's a phenomenon called
localization
why is this interesting from a
mathematical standpoint well if we let a
to be the adjacency Matrix then the
number of triangles can be expressed as
a sum of products of three entries in
The adjacency Matrix and that's a
non-linear function of these independent
random variables in The adjacency Matrix
and so standard large deviation Theory
simply doesn't apply to this setting
and and as I've mentioned we expect some
kind of unusual phenomena to arise like
localization
um the problem of studying
um triangle counts specifically
um in the upper tail is has been
referred to as the infamous upper tail
problem and it has inspired many new
ideas and probabilistic common Networks
today's Focus will be on large
deviations in duns graphs though there's
been really interesting work though
using very different techniques in the
sparse setting
um so a key idea for the earlish running
case which was done in Prior work is to
represent an artist for any random graph
as a graph on this was done by both
Chatterjee and barodon lubetsky and Zhao
and others the way this is done as has
been said in other talks is by
constructing What's called the empirical
graph on where we kind of divide up the
zero one square into N squared cells and
if I and J form an edge then the IJ
Celtics value one otherwise it takes
value zero here pictorially I've
represented ones by black and zero by
white
and so if we increase n and generate
these empirical graphons they'll get
more and more gray until finally they
really look like this gray region this
would be a typical realization if you
were to take n very large
um so like if the parameter of the Irish
freni is one-third then this gray region
would represent the value one-third in a
typical realization but what we're
interested in is atypical realizations
condition let's say I'm having twice as
many triangles as expected
um so because we can represent an artist
running graph as an empirical graph on
we can naturally describe large
deviations through the language of
graphons
um so this theory of graph on topology
has been developed by a line of work
um including these individuals
um as some of this has been mentioned
before so I'll go relatively quickly but
a graph on is of any measurable function
from the zero one square to the interval
0 and 1 that is symmetric
um here I'll let double the space w
collect all graph ones
two graphons can be compared by their
cut distance
um which is this expression
they can also be compared by their cut
metric which is their cut distance but
allowing one of the graphons to be kind
of scrambled more precisely if we let M
be the set of bijective measure
preserving Transformations and this
notation G Phi kind of
transposes uh each coordinate so if we
allow this this a certain kind of
restricted scrambling then the cut
metric is so defined
um the cut metric induces an equivalence
relation we'll say f and g are
equivalent if they're cotton metric
value is zero
and then we'll let uh W tilde be the set
of these equivalence classes uh where
the cut much or sorry cut metric value
of two equivalence classes is computed
according to their representative
elements
um and one well-known result is this uh
space w tilde equipped with a cut metric
is a compact metric space
all right because we're interested in
let's say subgraph counts
um we introduce the or we our work uses
the homomorphism density so for a fixed
sub graph H let's say a triangle
um the homomorphism density of H in a
graph on F is this integral where the
integrand is a product
um where like the i i j
um kind of range over the edges of the
subgraph
and like why does this kind of match up
with our notion of subgraph counts and
graphs well if we let FG to be the
empirical graphene associated with a
graph G than a rescaled version of what
we already saw to be the number of
triangles in G is actually the
homomorphism density of triangles in the
empirical graphene so there's this like
relationship that kind of matches up
with what we're trying to count in
actual graphs versus in graph ones and
there's like a related definition of
homomorphism density with respect to
equivalence classes not just graphics
um and it's also like a known fact is
that for any fixed graph age this map
from equivalence classes to homomorphism
densities is continuous under the
topology
all right so let's now go back and
consider the random graph GNP for a
fixed P between 0 and 1.
um and so like as I've alluded this
empirical graph on induces a
distribution on W tilde equipped with
the cut metric
and so that naturally induces a sequence
of probability measures denoted by this
PNP with a with a tilde where n and p
are just recording the parameters of the
graph
and so the prior work has done is to
derive an lgp for graphs in terms of
this P tilde
to State the prior work it's in terms of
a relative entropy so given a kind of a
base graph on W naught which is just the
uh a graph on which takes value p
then the relative entropy of
some other graph on F with respect to
the base graph on is this integral of
relative entropies where this function H
sub p is the usual relative entropy we
integrate over the whole square and we
kind of compare the value f x y to p
um what chatterjan varadan showed that
for any fixed P
um this sequence of probability measures
the right questions
yeah so in your previous formula you
have a w naught right that that's you're
assuming that that is
why right yes agree but because Yes W
naught in this context is is the
constant value graph on which takes
value to you that okay that was not
specifically
but foreign
the sequence of probability measures
satisfies an ldp with speed N squared
and the rate function I uh which
formally means that two things so an
upper bound or lower bound uh but for
any closed set F tilde
um when you take the probability of f
tilde take the log and then divide by
the speed N squared the uh like the
upper bound is the infimum over uh the
like H tilde's within uh the closed set
and similarly for an open set there is
like a kind of corresponding lower bound
where uh taking the like relative
entropy of an equivalence class uh you
just choose a representative element in
this context
all right and then in addition to
um determining probabilities of unlikely
events
um there's also known results about the
typical structure under a rare event
so uh for close at F tilde will um let F
till the star be the subset of f tilde
where the rate function is minimized
um then that set is non-empty and
Compact and moreover if you condition on
GNP kind of being described by the event
of tilde then
um
then this uh GNP is going to be close in
Cut metric to F tilde star
with high probability
so that's what this is saying and so in
particular if this optimal set is
actually a Singleton then that the
conditional distribution under the like
unlikely conditioning is going to be
concentrated at a single point
let's dive into the upper tail variation
problem so let um Phi P comma T be the
optimal value of the rate function can
like with the constraint of satisfying
um the like required triangle count
if the minimizer of fee is a constant
um then like that's interpreted as an
artist for any random graph with a
higher Edge density we'll call that
symmetry naturally
um sometimes the minimizer will be
non-constant that's called symmetry
breaking
um so it's actually very well understood
for done search for any graph so here's
what's known if G has parameter p and we
condition it on an elevated triangle
count let R be the edge probability for
which that elevated triangle count is
typical
and here is what um lubetsky and Zhao
determined
um so we'll consider only P and R such
that R is bigger than P because this is
for the upper tail variational problem
um the blue region is the symmetric
regime so if uh P the pair PR falls into
the blue region then conditioned on the
unlikely event the
um like conditional distribution of the
graph will mimic GNR
but it will have the same distribution
as GNR
in the white region that's the
non-symmetric regime the distribution
does not match GNR it's actually not
known what the distribution is but
they're able to rule out GNR if you're
wondering what this dashed line is
um prior work of I think this Chatterjee
and varadan showed that this region was
blue but didn't completely fill in the
Box
so what is left to know in this context
um there's no phase diagram known at
least not to my knowledge for
non-regular graphs
um I've already mentioned we don't know
what happens in the Symmetry breaking
regime
um what about other functionals not
necessarily subgraph counts a lot really
remains unknown in the urge for any
context
our Focus was actually on large
deviations outside of the early case
of course uh Brandon grass with and
homogeneities or various constraints are
common here are a few such models
and so large deviations in this context
are of natural interest and we expect
new phenomena to occur
um our focus is on block models we
construct a graph on with K blocks of
equal length
The Edge probabilities for these blocks
are specified by PAB where A and B both
range from 1 to K and are symmetric
our base graph on which is kind of the
analog of the constant valued graph on
from the eritreani case
it'll take value p a b on the A B Block
the random graph that we consider it has
KN vertices where n vertices are belong
to each block
we add edges independently with certain
probabilities so like we add edge i j
with this given probability I think it's
easier to explain a different way so if
vertex I is in block a and vertex J is
in Block B then I and J are connected by
an edge with probability PAB so in other
words we kind of look up the block
membership and then decide with what
probability we connect a given pair of
vertices
yes our model has like blocks of the
same length but that doesn't mean we
can't accommodate other kinds of block
models um so yes repeated values are
allowed and so that means we can
actually accommodate any rational length
blocks
and so there's kind of this relationship
between our sampled graph and of course
its empirical graph on representation
and so the distribution of graphs
naturally introduced like induces a
distribution
um
uh just as in the earlier training case
so it's very much very much analogous as
might be expected and so as in my
earlier training case our goal is to
derive an ldp for graphs in terms of
this P tilde
there is a subtlety that arises when
working with block models namely some
blocks can be equal to zero or one and
at first I might sound like a strange
Edge case but you you might just
consider let's say the bipartite urdish
for any case
um and so and that leads to issues when
calculating relative entropies of a
graph on F compared to the base graph on
W naught
um and so like in particular if uh like
p a b is a zero or one but a graph on F
does not agree then that like relative
entropy is going to shoot up to Infinity
and of course that issue does not arise
in the urge attorney context because
like the only interesting values of P
are strictly between zero and one
and our solution then is to restrict the
support appropriately for the lgp so uh
we'll let
Omega denote the pairs X Y such that the
base graph on is strictly between 0 and
1.
and we'll let W
um with a subscript of Omega be the
graphons that kind of agree with the
base graph on
and kind of uh going along that same
direction W tilde with an Omega is the
set of equivalence classes that agree in
an appropriate sense with the base graph
on
and so like certain like desirable
analytic properties are still preserved
when we like make this restriction to
Omega
like what should our rate function be
let's recall what what it was in the
urdish for any setting it was this
function I where okay again here we're
assuming that uh the base graph on W
naught is constant and takes value p
so a first guess would be to just
replace P with a W naught evaluated at x
y
okay that doesn't work because it's not
well defined on this uh like equivalence
class right because kind of depends like
if you take two different
representatives of a given equivalence
class they'll have different I values so
like already we see there are problems
and also we need to ensure lower semi
continuity of the rate function
and so our rate function that we
proposed was uh forgiven like
equivalence class F we'll take an ADA
ball around F and look at all uh all
graphons age which are close to F tilde
and then evaluate
um their Rel like their relative entropy
as
like in the using this definition and
infinity otherwise
okay that looks kind of complicated
others have since simplified this rate
function
so just kind of repeating this
definition uh what we showed is that the
sequence of probability measures
satisfies an ldp with speed N squared
and this wave function
but yeah
oh yeah yeah yeah right cut metrical
yeah
um and yeah since then
simplified the rate function it turns
out you don't need to take an ADA ball
you just consider only H's that have cut
metric value equal to zero compared to
filda this had been shown although it
seems like it was later by markering
under under an additional condition
and like we were interested in applying
our lgp to homomorphism densities
because that corresponds to subgraph
densities in graphs
um so let's fix a graph H for example
that has to be
um the regular so like let's say
triangle and let's let T Max kind of be
the maximal attainable value of the
homomorphism density and for T which is
like attainable but strictly lower
um let uh let Phi be kind of the best
rate function value subject to
respecting the constraint
foreign we showed that
um yeah the
probability of like achieving that value
if you take the log and appropriately
scale
um then that like that equals the
negative of this like Optimal value
um and also uh like looking into the
structure of the the optimal solution uh
let if we let F tilde star be the subset
uh where this rate function is minimized
uh that's not MTN Compact and moreover
there's a concentration property as we
saw before in the order for any case
and in particular if the optimizing set
is is a Singleton that means that the
conditional distribution is going to be
concentrated at a single point
let's talk about symmetry versus
symmetry breaking a good a natural
question would be do the minimizers of
the variational problem have the same
block structure as the base graph on
um well what we showed was for a fixed
irregular graph h
um there's if T the the like demanded
um density is larger than uh kind of
what's expected under the base graph on
but only by a little bit then the
minimizer of the variational problem is
unique and symmetric
also if
um T is very close to the maximal
attainable value then the minimizer is
also unique and symmetric so there are
these two extremes where we see a
symmetric solution
and regarding symmetry breaking in that
regime or like the just the definition
is that the optimizing graphene has a
different structure from the base graph
on we are able to establish symmetry
breaking for only certain special cases
of a base graph on
um so and then in these examples
combining with the symmetric results
that establishes what's called a
re-entrant phase transition because you
go from like symmetric to symmetry
breaking to symmetric as a parameter is
is changed
um we do know the specific boundary for
symmetry versus symmetry breaking in the
for a bipartite orders for any graphs
so that's kind of complementary to the
existing results of lubetsky and Zhao
who also identified this boundary in the
urdish or any case
um I'll sketch some of the proof ideas
so for the ldp context
um yeah I mean the the lower bound was
like relatively straightforce I'll focus
on the upper bound uh the prior work of
Chatterjee and Burdon really relies on
the fact that an urge for any random
graph remains invariant in law under
vertex for mutation so if you were to
like change the labels of the vertices
the likelihood of a graph remains
unchanged but that's not true in the
stochastic block model because the
probability of an edge depends on the
group memberships of the vertices
involved
we took a two-step approach in deriving
the upper bound
first we applied somewhere to use
regularity Lemma
um that allowed us to construct a
semorating net of flock graphons
and and then we could cover an event by
a finite Union of open balls centered on
the elements of this net
and that meant that we could that it was
sufficient to characterize the limiting
probability of each open ball
um would kind of reduce the problem
next we applied a method of pipes style
argument kind of reminiscent of um proof
of this anovs theorem
um sorry
oh um
yeah
um
I'll say like in this context if that's
okay so yeah so uh so the the meaning of
the word type is kind of the origin of
each vertex so
um each vertex is a member of some block
we consider the block membership the
type of the vertex
um and because it's type influences How
likely it forms edges with vertices of
other types
um when we go to compute relative
entropies and probabilities of certain
events happening We compare the base
graph on to the empirical graph on
according to how like uh the types were
aligned roughly speeding
um now I'll describe some proof ideas in
both symmetric regime
so here we fix p and some D greater than
or equal to two the purpose of all this
construction is for establishing the
symmetric regime for deregular graphs so
like for the triangle case D would be
equal to two
um then we Define
um PSI sub p as this function which is
kind of like related to our
um a relative entropy uh H sub P
um so if like for the triangle case it
would we would take uh we would just
take the square root of x over here
and then we let
um PSI hat denote the convex minor in of
PSI so this was a notion that was used
um in the lubetski style paper in order
to kind of study the Symmetry versus
symmetry breaking regimes and here is an
illustration from their paper
um so it's kind of a it's it's more like
a cartoon it's not to scale necessarily
um but it's an illustration of the
function uh X which is mapped to H sub P
of x to the one minus one over gamma
where like in this context gamma would
be an integer representing the degree of
the graph
and it has this form where like if p in
their context was the like erdish
running parameter
um then it has this like visual Behavior
with like certain uh inflection points
and such and uh have this red line tells
you kind of how the convex minor in that
behaves around uh around size so like
the convex minor would be this function
that kind of makes a departure by
following the red dashed line
um in order to keep going with the
symmetric or Gene proof um we introduced
like a certain representation of graph
on so if over here we have a graph on F
which has
um these this block structure
um we kind of
um introduce this like zooming in idea
where let's say to like zoom in on the
one two block over here so like first
row second column a given point here
which is let's say halfway through the
block uh going right and a quarter of
the way going down would be mapped to
the point that is at one half one
quarter
um
and then and then while just introducing
more notation uh the the D Norm of a
graph one is
then our our guarantee for the symmetric
regime
um is through what we refer to as a
convex minor condition inspired by the
work of lubetsky and Joe
um let W naught be the base graph on
where W naught is described by some p i
Js
um and let F be a graph on this that's
described by these fij so like this
would be an example of an F that can be
kind of written in terms of let's say f
1 1 F12 etc etc
um and we say that F satisfies the
Epsilon neighborhood minorite condition
if for all i j such that PHA is strictly
between 0 and 1. whenever X is in an
Epsilon neighborhood of the D Norm of
fij raced with d then the function PSI
and its convex minor and coincide so
pictorially here's again the
representation of
um of PSI so that's that'll be the black
line and PSI hat would would like follow
the red line
so let's say I and J are such that
um this D Norm is like somewhere over
here
but somewhere kind of safely within the
region where the convex migrate and it's
uh sorry where cyan is convex minor and
coincide then
um
then the Epsilon minor minor ink
condition would be satisfied for that
pair IJ but it has to be satisfied not
just for that IJ but for all of them so
if it holds for all of them then we say
that the Epsilon neighborhood minor in
condition is satisfied
foreign
goes like this so if W naught is our
base graph on
and F tilde is a minimizer of the
variational problem for the homomorphism
density for H which is a d regular graph
um Suppose there exists a sequence of
graphons FN such that first each FN
satisfies the Epsilon neighborhood
minoring condition
and the sequence FN converges in Cut
metric to F tilde the minimizer
and the I type rate function of the FNS
converges to the J type rate function of
epsilver then we can conclude that F
tilde matches the block structure of w
naught
now in terms of intuition for why this
convex minoring condition matters
um well that was real like remember that
the results of lubetsky and Zhao like
completely characterized the regime and
they went through this type of convex
minoring conditions so I think
understanding this I mean I would really
go to the lubetsky and gel paper because
somehow this is the like this convex
minor type thing is really what's
driving whether or not the Irish Bernie
case has a symmetric versus
non-symmetric solution
is
yeah I don't know so I really really
nice work with something else the the
spirit yeah
right we say symmetric is
foreign
again we only did this for a couple of
special cases
um it's just about constructing an
example that satisfies two properties so
that's of course non-symmetric and also
whatever the constraint is like
homomorphism density is satisfied and
also the relative entropy has to be
strictly lower than whatever it is for
the symmetric solution
um and yeah so you get like examples
like okay so if R is the symmetric value
then you construct graphons that have
like slightly larger values like or in
slightly smaller values in different
places and somehow that's going to have
like maintain the homomorphism density
but decrease the relative entropy and
it's very much on a case-by-case basis
and like one interesting question would
be to make this more systematic also we
don't claim anything about this being
the actual solution I really doubt that
it others so really pinpointing what is
the correct solution in the
non-symmetric regime I think would be
pretty difficult
there have been some subsequent
developments since our paper was posted
to Archive for example um Dupuy and
Medvedev
um considered yeah the in homogene
inhomogeneous ldps did we using a weak
convergence method
um the variational problems so I'll
mentioned that so we focused mainly on
subgraph counts so homomorphism density
but this group of authors considered the
spectral radius and I think maybe this
will be uh yeah I guess this we
mentioned later the Earth talked about
later this week
um also like sample path large
deviations have been considered uh I
guess I've mentioned the work of garbage
and pokerco they simplified the
expression for the rate function they
were also able to extend to irrational
block things so I mentioned how we can
accommodate rational block lengths but
really it was a little bit arbitrary I
guess that our blocks were of equal size
I'll mentioned some directions for open
problems uh yeah of course nailing down
this precise boundary between the
symmetric and non-symmetric regimes
we're very far from that
of course what happens in the Symmetry
breaking phase that's not even known in
the urge training context so it would be
interesting to start there I think
um also yeah this notion of uniqueness
and the Symmetry breaking phase is the
optimizer unique
um and what about large deviations for
non-regular subgraph nouns even in the
erdashery setting the results are
limited to D regular graphs
and that's that's all I had thank you
very much for your attention
[Applause]
in stochastic Rock models there's
basically two types of settings one
where you say deterministically how many
vertices there are of each of the
different phases you could also assume
that the the the types are chosen in IID
manner
I would guess that your results do not
extend to that setting no they don't
because
um unlikely events could then be due to
two different reasons right you could
yeah one is exponentially more likely
than right right so it could be just
because there are like more vertices in
the you know Community with higher
probability and that's what's driving
the elevated triangle but you're
probably going to get a face separation
once where you can get many triangles by
changing the type distribution
but at a certain moment that may no
longer be necessary no longer be
possible that's going to be
exponentially unlikely and then you're
going to have to do something similar to
what you're doing right so be
interesting to see like as like the
demand for triangles changes what's the
right kind of strategy what's the
optimal solution to this problem is it
kind of you know making communities yeah
right okay
can you just
so there are results by graphic and Coco
where they considered this random block
membership case they compared the ldps
at scale n and scale and square
close
so this is not exactly what you talk
about but what are the main challenges
if one wants to go to a bit sparser but
you know when you're in a random graphs
you don't have the compactness
I don't know so I know that that has
been working on the Irish ready setting
I'm not sure if it has all like the
block model case
bars
uh
yeah
but the ldp is
we have more time
thanks for the nice talk I I just have a
clarifying question about the results
when in the Symmetry case uh has the
same block model as the level is it also
can you also pin down the probabilities
in those blocks or is it just
oh no we didn't we didn't like identify
the solution we just uh showed that it
was symmetric
okay so yeah
it's hard to pin down
did I remember correctly it was like the
the solution to some like implicit
function and so I think it might be
difficult to finish
um
does it happen sometimes or could it
happen that you have more symmetry in
than in the original graph I mean if you
start with a two block model it happens
at your minimizer is
homogeneous and erdogs
and will it be interesting to
investigate that
sounds like an edge case
I have a feeling that wouldn't really
happen because you could probably lower
the entropy while maintaining whatever
Target by kind of increasing one and
decreasing the others
so is it is there an upper bound on the
number of blocks that the uh that the
minimizer has as a function of the size
of the subgraph whose counts your uh
you're pushing and for that matter is it
even known that there is a finite upper
bound or are there flipping that around
are there any natural problems where the
optimizer
really has a you know some continuously
varying
graph on rather than a piecewise
constant one so we did not investigate
that but that's pretty interesting like
if somehow the function influences the
solution in terms of like finiteness or
not yeah I don't know but
I think it's not even known for the Etta
shrenia case right people's sort of
conjecture it's continuous but nobody
knows
am I is that correct
yes
I mean maybe you have a replica symmetry
breaking solution as a physicist but no
I think it's not known even for it is
when you're in triangles
in some sense we saw earlier these
celebrations where
um
foreign
[Applause]